i ran into you somewhere and rihanna
hadn't she had really never even heard
of at this point and you walked up to me
and said that's my artist and i was
struck by that never forget those words
that's my artist and you were proud man
and you were like wow this is a
discovery of mine and uh and then she
exploded and then and you know she lit
up
how hands-on are you in terms of
managing her career well we actually
manage her now um we didn't manage in
the beginning i signed as a an artist on
defunct how did you know where do you me
where do you where do you find a girl
like that she actually walked into my
office she has a lawyer scott felcher
and uh he knew jay brown who works with
me and uh they made the introduction he
played him this song
upon the replay which was the first
single she had already and um
she walked into the office and you know
i heard the record i was really afraid
of the record it was so big that i
thought the record would be bigger than
her right i thought the record she would
be the pawn the replay girl forever yeah
so but i took the meeting anyway i said
uh let me just see let me just meet her
and uh
beautiful when i met her that day i knew
she was a star like just her look the
way she walked into a room in her
confidence and she performed in my
office and she was what 17 years old at
that point 16. 16. and she has the
confidence of she's like an old soul in
a sense right absolutely so she walks in
your office and what she just belts out
of tune bell's out of tune she performs
and i and i tell her uh
there's no way out of this office i
signed her that day wow
wow when she's your artist
she i mean she must be generating a
fortune right
yeah well i mean if you retire tomorrow
you could just run her career and make a
ton of dough am i correct no
i'm wrong no i have expensive tastes